yo here's a hot take I would [ __ ]  who do you think got the nicest dies on  Team USA decent right oh yeah he got a  dump it who Drake yeah I like Drake look  at them thighs bro come on bro we Feast  on them yeah don't you think bro nah but  they got some noses though are they  Jewish  no I said that because they look really  attractive they got some pretty ass  dudes that's what I get how am I gay for  calling that up because you want us  hide in your [ __ ] meat right now  cause you just mad bricked up that's why  you gay because you don't talk about how  cute they are yeah we can acknowledge  they call me gay yeah I be saying  Ronaldo's the best looking soccer [ __ ]  but they got a few of them look at him  he thick bruh but you want to dip him in  some like milk chocolate or something  like that like dip him in something he  thick bro right